how much have you actually sort of
seemed to enjoy the secrecy on this
movie and as a follow up there is talk
about a film that might be around about
a much younger Han Solo would you be
wanting to approve the answer the place
that chance and there's not a film you'd
like to see what was the beginning of
the the question was really you see the
sorts of almost enjoy the secrecy or
Venice yet has that very kind of suited
you not to give things away we kind of
covered it away yeah no I have actually
relished this entire experience in a way
that I had not anticipated and I think a
lot of the credit for that goes to JJ
and Larry this is a rare experience in
my old life and and I'm very grateful
for it as far as the movie featuring a
young Han Solo I I don't know what to
think about that I am glad that somebody
else is gonna have the burden of being
young and and take care of that part
it's well beyond my understanding
control and I will and I of course want
nothing to do with it in the nicest
possible way and I'm but I know that it
will be well done and well-guarded and
it's not nothing to do with me
you